eduardo manejo de la ciudad de mexico a
querétaro la función de nos da la
distancia total que eduardo manejo en
kilómetros de horas después de su salida
cuál es la mejor interpretación del
siguiente enunciado y me dan este
enunciado que tengo aquí de prima de 2
es igual a 100 esta vez se encarga de
que escribas el problema en tus apuntes
que pausa es el vídeo y que pienses en
qué crees que signifique esta expresión
que tengo aquí pon atención a las
unidades apropiadas
bien es hora de trabajar dos juntos sí
es la distancia que eduardo manejo de
hama notable sirve es la distancia
manejada entonces para obtener de prima
necesitamos derivar esta expresión con
respecto al tiempo por lo que una forma
de pensarlo es que de prima es la tasa
de cambio instantánea de dem con
respecto al tiempo déjame notarlo es la
tasa de cambio instantánea de prima es
la tasa de cambio instantánea y ambas
son funciones del tiempo por lo tanto
una forma de ver a de prima de 2 igual a
100 es que significa que déjame
escribirlo de prima de 2 igual a 100
significa que y ahora cuál es nuestro
tiempo bueno nuestro tiempo es este
este es nuestro tiempo en horas dos
horas entonces significa que
igual a dos horas después de su salida
eduardo manejo a una tasa de cambio
instantánea de eduardo manejo a una tasa
de cambio instantánea bdem
y déjeme ponerlo con este color una tasa
de cambio instantánea de 100 eso es muy
importante de 100 y ahora cuáles son
nuestras unidades
bueno la distancia está dada en
kilómetros y el tiempo está dado en
horas por lo tanto nuestra unidad de
tiempo va a ser kilómetros por hora
kilómetros por hora y esta sería nuestra
interpretación bien hagamos otro ejemplo
más un tanque con agua se drena la
función fem nos da el volumen del
líquido en el tanque en litros después
de minutos eso es importante la función
be nos da el volumen del líquido en el
tanque en litros ok
después de t minutos cuál es la mejor
interpretación del siguiente enunciado
la pendiente de la recta tangente a la
gráfica debe ente igual a 7 es igual a
menos 3 así que de nuevo pausa el vídeo
e intenta hacer lo mismo que hicimos en
el ejemplo anterior
escribe tu interpretación y pon mucha
atención a las unidades apropiadas
muy bien vamos a analizar un poco lo que
está sucediendo
bueno ven es el volumen b es el volumen
y es una función del tiempo el volumen
está dado en litros y el tiempo en
minutos y nos hablan de la pendiente de
la recta tangente a la gráfica de p
bueno esto de aquí es simplemente de
prima de prima así que si tomamos la
derivada de esta función con respecto al
tiempo vamos a obtener abm prima de tm
recuerda
estas son funciones del tiempo esta es
una función del tiempo y también lo será
de prima de t
además dice que ve prima ente igual a 7
es igual a menos 3 entonces déjame
dejarlo claro esto de aquí
nos da la pendiente de la recta tangente
esto nos da la pendiente de la recta
tangente y nos dicen que mi prima
un tiempo de té igual a 7 de primer de 7
esto es igual a menos 3 nuestra tasa de
cambio del volumen con respecto al
tiempo es igual a menos 3 entonces
puedes verlo de esta manera déjame
escribirlo después de 7 minutos y lo voy
a poner con su respectivo color después
de siete minutos el tanque se drena con
una tasa de cambio instantánea el tanque
se drena con una tasa de cambio
instantánea de
y justo para esto necesitamos el cálculo
para obtener estas tasas de cambio
instantáneas
tal vez estés tentado a decir que la
tasa de cambio de drenado es de menos 3
litros por minuto pero recuerda el -3
nos muestra que el volumen está
decreciendo así que una forma de
pensarlo es que esté menos 3
ya lo tenemos contemplado cuando decimos
que el tanque se drena si fuera positivo
entonces el tanque se estaría llenando
pero se está drenando entonces se drenan
con una tasa de cambio instantánea de 3
y las unidades serán litros por minuto
como sé cuáles son las unidades
correctas bueno la función de volumen
está dada en litros y el tiempo está
dado en minutos así que al tomar la
derivada con respecto al tiempo
obtenemos litros por minutos y hemos
terminado nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo